♪ ♪
>> Greg: WHILE CNN MAKES
GOOGLE EYES AT ADAM SCHIFF, ONE
OF THEIR ANALYSTS AND FORMER
CLINTON LACKEY MADE UP A
CONVERSATION WITH REPUBLICANS.
HE TWEETED "OVERHEARD
CONVERSATION BETWEEN TWO
REPUBLICAN SENATORS WHO ONLY
WATCH FOX NEWS.
IS THIS STUFF REAL?
I HAVEN’T HEARD ANY OF THIS
BEFORE.
I THOUGHT IT WAS ALL ABOUT A
SERVER.
IF HALF THE STUFF SCHIFF IS
SAYING IS TRUE, WE ARE UP
[BLEEP]’S CREEK.
HOPE THE WHITE HOUSE HAS
EXCULPATORY EVIDENCE."
AFTER THE TWEET MADE MUCH
PRAISE, INCLUDING FROM
"THE WASHINGTON POST," HE LATER
ADDED, "OKAY, MAYBE I MADE UP
THE CONVERSATION BUT YOU KNOW
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE
THINKING.
WHAT DOES THIS MATTER?
HE JUST REVEALED THE ENTIRE
ANTI-TRUMP PLATFORM WITH "YOU
KNOW EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE
THINKING.
THE LAST FEW YEARS OF PANIC HAVE
BEEN FROM THE MEDIA BELIEVING
THEY CAN MIND READ.
THEY ACCUSED EVERYONE OF RACISM
AND OPENLY DEMONIZE TRUMP
SUPPORTERS BECAUSE THEY KNOW
WHAT IS IN EVERYONE’S HEAD.
YET THEY ARE ALWAYS WRONG ABOUT
REALITY.
MAYBE IT IS THEIR ILL-ADVISED
MIND READING THAT LEADS TO THESE
PREDICTED CATASTROPHES THAT
NEVER, EVER COME AND THAT MAKES
THEM EVEN MORE SAD AND MORE
NERVOUS.
OF COURSE, LOCKHART LIE GOT
THOUSANDS OF RETWEETS, WHICH IS
FINE WITH HIM HERE THE LIE IS
WHAT HE BELIEVES.
CNN, WILL THEY ADMONISH HIM?
NOT WHEN THEY ARE BUSY WITH
THEIR OWN FACULTY NATIONS.
YOU MAY
REMEMBER JOE LOCKHART, THE PRESS
BILL CLINTON DURING HIS INFAMOUS
SEX SCANDAL.
YOU WERE JUST A TOT.
BUT HIS WHOLE STRATEGY IS
SAYING, I KNOW WHAT EVERYONE IS
THINKING IS THINKING.
>> Dana: AND THIS IS THE
TRIAL, EVERYONE IS POINTING OUT
YOUR THOUGHTS AND OPINIONS DON’T
WORK.
EVIDENCE IS WHAT IS PRESENTED AT
A TRIAL.
AND IT IS TEMPTING AND KIND OF
FUN TO MAKE UP A CONVERSATION TO
PUT UP 20 ON TWITTER.
MY FRIEND DID SOMETHING ABOUT
WHAT TRUMP SAID.
IT SEEMED LIKE SOMETHING TRUMP
WOULD SAY BUT HE DIDN’T SAY AND
IT CAUSED A WHOLE FIRESTORM.
ADAM SCHIFF MADE UP A WHOLE
PHONE CONVERSATION AND HAS PAID
THE PRICE EVER SINCE.
WE KEEP MAKING THESE COMPARISONS
COME OF THIS IMPEACHMENT VERSUS
CLINTONS.
I DO WONDER WHAT IT WOULD’VE
BEEN LIKE IF SOMEONE LIKE JOE
LOCKHART, THE PRESS
SECRETARY THEN, HAD HAD THE
TOOLS OF SOCIAL MEDIA TO BE ABLE
TO DIRECTLY COMMUNITY IT WITH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE RATHER THAN
THROUGH THE MEDIA.
>> Greg: GIVEN THAT IS THE
TOPIC OF CLINTON’S IMPEACHMENT
WAS ABOUT SEX, CAN YOU IMAGINE?
THE GIFS.
GIFS OR GIFS?
ANYWAY.
>> Jesse: I KNOW WHAT SOME OF
THE REPUBLICANS ARE THINKING.
I’M STARVING AND I CAN’T WAIT TO
GET ON TO BE 20 "HANNITY"
TONIGHT.
AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE THINKING,
I’M STARVING AND I CAN’T WAIT TO
GET TO IOWA.
THEY’LL HAVE BETTER PLACES TO
BE.
ADAM SCHIFF IS LIKE A HUMAN
SLEEPING PILL.
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT BUT THE MEDIA
WILL TELL YOU THE GUY IS LIKE A
CAN OF RED BULL.
AND YOU’RE WRONG ABOUT THE
RATINGS.
THEY HAVE BEEN DOWN SINCE DAY
ONE, THEY ARE DOWN FROM THE
HOUSE HEARINGS AND THEY ARE WAY
DOWN SINCE THE MUELLER HEARING.
I DIDN’T THINK THE PEOPLE ARE
REALLY PAYING ATTENTION.
JOE LOCKHART, WE’VE NOW COME
FROM REPORTING GOSSIP TO JUST
MAKING UP GOSSIP AND REPORTING
IT.
THAT IS HOW BAD IT IS.
>> Greg: SHOULD CNN FIRE JOE
LOCKHART?
>> Juan: THAT IS A GOOD
QUESTION.
I DON’T THINK SO, THOUGH.
>> Greg: I DON’T KNOW, JUST A
QUESTION.
>> Juan: HE IS NOT THERE IS A
STRAIGHT NEWS GUY BUT I WILL SAY
HIS DESCRIPTION AS SATIRE IS
WEAK AND WRONG AND HE SHOULD
HAVE JUST SAID HE WAS WRONG AND
I THINK CNN SHOULD HAVE SAID IT
WRONG BUT I NOTICED, IN THE WAY
THAT DEMOCRATS GO AFTER SENATORS
WHO ARE REPUBLICAN SENATORS WHO
ARE SLEEPING, NODDING OFF OR
WHATEVER, NOW EVERYBODY IS
PICKING ON -- THIS IS LIKE,
DISTRACTION, DISTRACTION,
DISTRACTION.
I NOTICED THAT THE RNC AND THE
TRUMP RAPID RESPONSE TEAM MADE A
BIG DEAL ABOUT WHAT JOE LOCKHART
DID.
AGAIN, THEY DON’T WANT TO DEAL
WITH THE FACTS OF WHAT SCHIFF IS
PRESENTING, WHAT SYLVIA --
>> Greg: MIND-READING!
>> Juan: NOW, LET’S HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT GOSSIP.
>> Jesse: HOW DOES JUAN GET
ALL THE REPUBLICAN TALKING
POINTS AND I DON’T GET ANY.
SEND ME SOME EMAILS.
>> Greg: SHOULD WE JUST GET
YOUR -- I WOULD LIKE TO RUN SOME
TAPE.
THIS IS THE MEDIA COMPLETING
ABOUT SLEEPY SENATORS.
>> SOME SENATORS MAY BE EVEN
LEAVING BEFORE TONIGHT WAS DONE.
IT’S ODD AND NOT SOMETHING I
EXPECTED.
>> IT’S A TERRIBLE LOOK TO THE
PUBLIC.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE
SUPPOSED TO BE LISTENING TO A
HEARING AND MAKING A DECISION ON
WHAT IS BEING PRESENTED.
>> YOU FIND IT TOO ANNOYING OR
FRUSTRATING OR UNCOMFORTABLE TO
SIT FOR HOURS.
LISTEN, YOU CAN RESIGN TOMORROW
AND GO GET ANOTHER JOB.
>> MANY OF THE SENATORS OF BOTH
PARTIES WERE NOT AT THEIR DESKS
AT DIFFERENT TIMES DESPITE THE
RULES BUT IT’S NOT LIKE THE
FUTURE OF THE REPUBLICAN STATE.
OH WAIT, IT IS!
SEE, WE TURNED IT AROUND?
IT’S BRILLIANT.
>> Juan: I THINK
DIANNE FEINSTEIN
IS GOING TO HAVE TO RESIGN
BECAUSE SHE LEFT AT 9:30 P.M.
LAST NIGHT AND IT WENT ON AND
MAYBE THEY HAD SOMETHING BESIDES
WATER OR MILK TO DRINK THEY WOUL
STAY UP.
BUT AGAIN, IT SHOWS THE HOUSE
DIDN’T HAVE ENOUGH EVIDENCE TO
COMEPRESENT THE CASE.
TO THE SENATORS NOT LISTENING TO
EVERYTHING THEY ARE PRESENTING
SHOWS THE HOUSE IS NOT GIVING
THEM A COMPELLING REASON TO SIT
AND LISTEN TO EVERY SINGLE
DETAIL BECAUSE THEY THINK THIS
IS A VERY SERIOUS MATTER.
I THINK IT’S INTERESTING NOW
THAT THE MEDIA IS CONCERNED THAT
POLITICIANS AREN’T DOING THE
SAME WORK THAT REGULAR PEOPLE
DO, HAVING TO STAY UNTIL THE END
OF THEIR JOBS INSTEAD OF LEAVING